y at il eu de la vie sur mars le robot
américain persévérance apportera
peut-être des réponses à cette question
que se posent les scientifiques depuis
bien longtemps
le premier soupçon remonte à la fin du
19e siècle
on croyait observer des lignes sur la
planète ce sont les canaux de mars
l'oeuvre d'une vie intelligente pour les
scientifiques dans les archives au 6
mars est source de fantasmes comme la en
1950 avec de l'ironie dans l'auto
l'inquiétante planète rouge et vert
national de laquelle en a distingué une
âme de vapeur que certains ont assimilé
à de formidables explosion il n'en
fallait pas plus pour ressusciter le
mythe de l'existence des martiens nos
aînés d'un milliard d'années -distants
seulement 1 70 millions de kilomètres
aussitôt on s'est souvenu de ce pilote
de l'aviation américaine qui décollant
de nuit le 1er octobre 49 avait aperçu
une clarté bizarre dans le ciel suivie
de l'apparition d'une soucoupe volante
il a vécu le temps
émanant de disparaître le mythe des
bonhommes verts
il est enterré au fil des explorations
spatiales
à commencer par les premières photos de
mars prise en août 1965 par la sonde
marine heures quatre a moins de 10000 km
le verdict de marine r4 à rassurer le
monde mars à la physionomie bonhomme de
la lune l'effrayante invasion de la
terre par les martiens n'est plus
désormais qu'un conte pour enfants
turbulents
avec les missions spatiales des années
70 mars s'avère être une planète très
froides sèche et surexposé aux
ultraviolets des conditions peu propices
à la vie sauf peut-être dans le passé
sous forme microbienne en attendant de
trouver des traces de cette existence
l'homme se concentre sur le voyage
spatial envoyer des hommes sur mars déjà
envisagé dans ce reportage de 1972
vers la fin des années 70 on concentrera
tous les efforts sur le voyage maxime
grand voyage pourrait être entrepris le
2 novembre 1980 avait calculé les
experts on a semblerait en orbite un
gigantesque vaisseau nucléaires pesant
des centaines de tonnes et l'on partirai
pour un voyage de plus de deux ans
[Musique]
george bush l'avait à son tour promis en
1990 un échec
puis en 2015 une entreprise néerlandaise
avait recruté des volontaires pour les
envoyer sur mars avant d'abandonner le
projet en 2019 poser le pied sur la
planète rouge
c'est aujourd'hui le projet d'elon musk
le milliardaire américain espère envoyer
des humains en 2024